doc gynéco tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup et une personne à contacter la
production pour nous raconter une
histoire qu'elle a eue avec tours ouais
moi oui avec toi elle nous a contacté le
personne et je voulais absolument de
faire là la surprise ce soir
est ce que le prénom de brigitte te dit
quelque chose comme déjà il c'est parce
qu'il a fait une erreur
non non brigitte tu ne te rappelle pas
brigitte non je vais faire entrer
brigitte qui est avec nous ce soir et
[Applaudissements]
notre site merci d'être là brigitte
alors est-ce que vous reconnaissez
brigitte alors oui si vous faites dans
laquelle vous cassez alors je travaille
dans une maison d'édition d'accord ouais
vous habite à pas est ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose
là ça commence à m'intéresser pourquoi
repa livre au discours laisse que se
livrent ils vivent reddition alors je ne
dis pas de bêtises connaissez bien
bruno oui puisque vous avez eu une
petite aventure avec lui voilà c'est ça
il ya 11 ans ya onze ans cette histoire
serait souvenu
excusez-moi brigitte très jolie en tout
cas oui alors doc sans rigoler est-ce
que vous rappelez de brigitte banon
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quand
vous avez rencontré doc et on en 2008
dans une boîte de nuit parisienne chez
castel ah oui
ça commence à commença à lui dire
quelques dates pour ces frères rien ce
que c'est que cette histoire non
qu'est-ce que ça vous dit quelque chose
castel oui non mais brigitte surtout
mais n'ont toujours pas alors comment ça
s'est passé pour nous raconter pour le
rafraîchir la mémoire
oui donc d'été à nice on a des amis il
avait il est en train de boire de l'eau
certainement nombreux panneaux très bien
mais bon je pense du soda voilà du soda
et puis un ses amis qui est venu me voir
demandant si je voulais pour un verre
donc oui si j'ai fait la connaissance de
doc on a discuté littérature mais public
là on a bien accroché en fait voilà je
parle que foot 7 10 heures des sports
alors qu'est ce que ça vous dit quelque
chose ou pas non à la fin de la soirée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que c'était
une surprise pour vous à la base un
ouais ouais
à la fin de la soirée c'est vrai que oui
c'est moi d'accord voilà vous bien alors
j'ai proposé de venir prendre un verre
la maison quoi est il a quatre et il a
dit chocolat
alors alors aller alors et donc oui
eloquin on a passé la nuit ensemble
vous avez passé la nuit ensemble voilà
oui non mais dans le même lit vraiment
oui bon boulot non mais c'est pas
évident même si oui comment
comment et la galoche j'ai eu de la
gueule
ah oui laisser leur sang le lendemain
donc parce que vous l'avez revue au
lendemain je suis parti travailler j'ai
laissé un petit mot avec mon numéro de
téléphone et
malheureusement il m'a jamais rappelé
voilà le goujat oui alors qu'est-ce que
tu te rappelles parce que je sais que
brillante tu nous en as tu une fête on
avait parlé à l'époque
ouais m'a dit que tu a regretté voila
voila c'est dépassé oui et que tu as
envie de la revoir c'est pour ça que
j'ai été surpris ce soir en fait je
rigole de peter j'étais très bien
reconnu ça va est ce que est ce que
voulez vous faire un petit bisou quand
même parce que c'était bien vrai petit
bijou
donc ça tu garde un bon souvenir de
brigitte pas parce que je sais que tu en
avais parlé c'est c'est qu'on a plein de
potes en commun et qui m'a dit c'est
vrai que voilà il avait connu brigitte
et il avait envie de la revoir comme ça
même par amitié parce que l'asse est est
ce que ça te fait plaisir ça fait super
plaisir je revois on va avoir un verre
ensuite au café à côté ensemble
[Rires]
alors alors brigitte elle est très
contente vraiment de devoir se soient
noyés depuis bon donc c'était y accoster
à 10 ans il ya onze ans la 11e et et des
contente de voir doc
parce que depuis tu as he fais ta vie ou
pas je suis toujours célibataire
mais déjà un petit garçon de 10 ans qui
s'appelle t dit quoi et si c'est pas le
fils de si je suis là ce soir c'est
vraiment pour une raison précise
ouais de cette nuit d'amour en fait est
né un petit garçon s'appelle teddy soir
je voudrais savoir si tu es prêt à
rencontrer à ton fils teddy
oui je veux bien c'est vrai
non franchement c'est donc tu te
souviens de ça ou pas tu te souviennes
brigitte pas fait plaisir mais grave
suis vraiment heureux vraiment bah oui
ça on a quelque chose de ce soir était
heureux tu le savais pas du tout n'en
doutez pas du tout mais c'est une balle
de vrais mandat non mais protégez-vous
ya onze ans on est sorti vraiment semble
donc le prends bien est ce que tu es
dyéla ce soir es10 et là ce soir il a
envie de voir
c'était mon papa doc je vous demande
d'accueillir teddy est là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
au boulet voilà pour la caméra cachée de
grecs vont naître à une caméra cachée en
direct devrait reverser comment vous
appelez ouais mais brigitte était
formidable
[Applaudissements]